i have to say this is extremely worrying
situation
and what we do need to see is the
international community standing up to
russian aggression in support of ukraine
i never thought i'd be seeing something
like this
in my my lifetime it's really really
scary what's happening um it's not clear
what's happening at the border but
anything that de-escalates the situation
is extremely welcome and so it's really
important that as allies we stand
together in the face of russian
aggression
one thing i want to see is um i do want
to see the government um having a tough
line on sanctions
um russia must really know the serious
consequences
if we invade if they invade ukraine in
terms of what happens and we just can't
avoid for this of um afford for the
situation to become volatile
um you talk about sanctions um i know
that your leader uh zakir stama has
suggested retaining millions of pounds
of russian link cash donated to the
conservative party who should they
return it to
um yeah you're right correct um what
we've um called for the government is to
do more to tackle russian money in the
uk and what we've seen is under the
tories um london has become the center
of russian money laundering and what
we're calling for is the government to
reform companies house um to prevent
sham companies being set up and it's
really important that the government
takes action on this and shows some
leadership on on this act on this
particular issue and it's something that
labour has been calling for for some
time now